[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about whatever we want
kiss no did you guys see that that the
restaurant takedown by mr. Matt Oh Matt
sir I saw it the video I didn't see it
it's tight so Matt sir
for those of you guys that don't know he
was a former UFC welterweight champion
he knocked out GSP is a black belt in
jujitsu
so karate he's now a Hall of Famer as
well Wow like people don't know how high
some of these guys martial arts level is
and so like black belts make brown belts
look like [ __ ] brown belt to make
blue belts and purple belts look like
[ __ ] blue belt to make people regular
people look like [ __ ] and so this is
just a regular drunk dude trying to [ __ ]
with this guy he was just like haha okay
whatever just calm down sir
the newest video on Instagram yeah I
would like to watch
[Applause]
so Jill have a shirt over his face the
shirt pirate or something you need good
news for that - ain't got no
you could kiss him if he wants to is
that a casino needs a Vegas this is the
biggest or looks like a Vegas restaurant
or something this is this is the day
he's about to get inducted into UFC Hall
of Fame oh yeah like what do you do
while you wait oh yeah how do you spend
the night before UFC h OS induction used
to do some [ __ ] drunk that was
threatening waiters then tries to swing
on you
hashtag did it i want to see how he took
him down and got him there I want to see
that before
some people like they start recording in
the middle yeah there's another video of
the this guy if you guys know his name
is Ryan Hall he's like a jujitsu legend
yeah same thing happened in the
restaurant where a guy was like going
crazy yeah and he just took him down and
he submitted him like super fast yeah
yeah that's so easy for that dude lay on
the [ __ ] I've been doing that [ __ ] I
wish it kind of happened this is just a
low-key wish but um that it would happen
to one of the female UFC fighters like
were someone's like trying to hit on her
and she's like no [ __ ] I said no he
tries to like yeah but that guy's not
gonna really fight back though oh if he
gets like wrestled down by a girl he's
gonna fight back you still that happened
oh yeah she's like I want to do this
anymore that's like no please choke me
out I'm gonna she just starts vomit on
his face okay yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
but yeah yeah just bleeding all over the
place she's just licking it employee
Nastase okay she just treats him like a
punching bag yeah cos girls are like I
think girls could get away with assault
all day everyone will clap oh yeah like
if a guy was like her baby what's up and
then she just clocked them in the face
it won't be like
girl yeah if I saw like Ronda Rousey
beat the [ __ ] out of some dude they'll
be so tight did you see her fighting
girls all the time but you don't know
how good these girls are too but they
train with dudes all the time in their
training caps and I would love to see
her [ __ ] up a dude I need to look for
more videos I gotta find some girl fight
videos like that you have to I have to
do it this is something that is
necessary like I feel like on a weekly
basis no maybe on a daily I watch fight
videos on YouTube professionally or like
on the streets or everything it's just
something that I it's it's for my soul
oh you talking about street fights right
yes it's like I do that or I watch a
professional fight so I I just have to
keep doing it I probably watch more
street fights than I watch professional
fights it's like 80% of street fights
and I like my keywords or didn't know
guy had you Jitsu or didn't know guy
could box right cuz it got the box is
always chill cuz they know what they can
do you know so the guys like it's always
a drunk guy in the dude's face thank you
oh [ __ ] you up and the guys i got my
buddy chill out and then he's like slaps
the guys girl or something he goes all
right cool I've never seen hands so fast
in my life
and the guy as he's getting punched in
the face he's still talking [ __ ] will
[ __ ] you up any pause well if it's like
that Joe Rogan's story where one dude
like that there road-raging two dudes oh
yeah and then one guy and the other guys
are like going at it but then they
realize that they're both you had like
professional fighters oh she did you
guys see that recent one of the one in
San Francisco this guy this one guy
kicked this Asian hackers car yeah and
he came out and he spotted [ __ ] you
gotta watch it yeah yeah and then
another dude comes and tackles the asian
guy and he's like you gotta it's not
worth it bro you gotta calm down it's
like why did he tackle the Asian dude
when the white guy was addressing all
the whole time like I was the one that
threw the cake to tackle the white guy
yes you hit me yeah bro why would you
even get him that's pretty much two
white guys versus Asian guy yeah yeah
but too bad that [ __ ] asian guy would
light both their asses up that [ __ ] was
tight
he was like bobbin and Weavin - I
haven't seen this man I replayed this
[ __ ] over and over
blah blah blah and then look at this guy
dude like a flying ski jumping on him
with the right but in the other guy
pulled off the other foot we could have
run it away look at him right away boy
no no no no so then he goes behind the
car and he takes a picture of it listen
to this guy this guy's funny
look he's taking pictures of his license
plate I didn't kick you that it's not
worth it wait wait wait he kicked this
star though hey let me work this car
real quick let me just go broom broom up
in this [ __ ]
then he kicked that [ __ ] though that
second guy's annoying that [ __ ] next
shark got an interview from the actor
and what he was saying is like he was he
was in his RA with his buddy and he
wanted to you know kind of rev the
engine to show his friend like you know
everyone does that when you get a new
car like hey listen to this from room
right yeah so he did that and then that
that white guy with the tank top what
started like right won't you shut the
[ __ ] up and then like I guess he didn't
he didn't like that and then they just
had like a back-and-forth conversation
you could read like the exact details
but basically what ended up happening
was he says something like he called him
like hey what you in there with your
boyfriend or whatever is that your
girlfriend you know calling them gay and
stuff like that and he's all like if you
don't shut up I'll make you my
girlfriend
and then basically he's like man you got
a daughter with you you know be a good
example and the dude just kicks his car
so then after he kicks his car he's all
he'll know so he gets out and then he
swung out him the gut the the white guy
with the tank tops swung at him so he
returned shots and then I think at that
moment that's when the other white dude
came and tackled the Asian actors makes
no sense and in he's they're telling him
it's not worth hitting that guy's like
dude are you getting involved and if you
saw he said you saw everything right but
you still decided to tackle the [ __ ]
Asian guy who got hit right open but if
you saw everything why did you wait for
it to get that bad to get involved yeah
I wanted to step in the middle and
separate the two or maybe it wasn't like
he was going after the Asian type of
thing you should maybe he was just going
after the dude that was like any company
in the fight yeah but the asian guy is
fighting out of self-defense still
exactly because you don't chop you if
you pull the aggressor off the asian
guys not gonna keep fighting but yes
just like you kicked my car yeah no I'm
on yourself because you know what ended
up happening is we
that when that bald white guy took down
the asian dude the guy the white guy
with the the tank top guy tried to swing
while he was on the ground yeah they
would jump yeah the other guys pulled
that other guy off and then the asian
guy stood up and he was able to like
defend himself but i said like if you
watched I watched that video of multiple
times while he was on the ground the
tank top guy try to not like try to
punch him really why everybody needs a
pepper spray man that's just what I said
everybody jail there's a thing called
pepper jail it's thicker
straight line no blowback see that's
what I need you know what I mean
cuz that [ __ ] was quick I'm dude like a
squeegee behind your [ __ ] eye [ __ ]
and that would have been the [ __ ] non
viral video of the year I gave it to
Mariel tell her to hold hold it while
she's walking oh yeah it might be too
late I was watching this video of a guy
that's like [ __ ] robbed over 200
people and he says like you know there's
a lot of things that people believe but
it never [ __ ] works and he goes but
the thing that deters a lot of you know
people that rob is pepper spray like but
the ones that spray not the squirt ones
and then he's like not the one that
Davis recommend you know don't keep it
in your purse like it's like hold it in
your hand
I don't even carry pepper spray bro it's
a holder
- [ __ ] gulls yeah and and he's like
he's like be careful when you're driving
up the driveway he's like that's one of
his favorite targets and a lot of people
go for that one
we're like because once you drive in if
they could run in at the last minute you
get out of your car your trap you can't
go anywhere and then another one is a
yeah so you know when you drive into
your garage like sometimes they'll just
wait and then as you're pulling into all
running like that yeah yeah
and then there's no way out for you cuz
you're you're gonna open the car door
you're like oh [ __ ] it right that's why
you lock your car you keep the car and
you start trying to run them over inside
the garage when you open the garage door
your neighbors just blood everywhere I
had to do what I had to do know wondered
um should have to see all the time yeah
so my deepest you're gonna break down
your whole house dude don't try to get
to the kitchen and [ __ ] I'm gonna
pull those these [ __ ] no wonder
it all makes sense now
but I still didn't get robbed and
they're all dead it's about to happen -
[ __ ] rob me dude come on
yeah you look too poor yeah you have to
rob people that aren't easy it's no
challenge dude it's not fun it's not fun
gonna deter them rob me in my fanny pack
from a baby dude challenge yourself
remember challenge yourself
I can't watch street fights Wow why does
it make you feel sad yeah like maybe a
really bad just two consenting adults uh
kind of not once I try to defend
themselves unless they're like both like
what imma send you a video of this man
walking with his lady in the park and a
guy slaps her ass the guy turns around
and likes these two dudes up I bet you
liked that video no no I don't like I
still don't like stuff like that there's
one video like you and it's controlled
and it is consenting because they both
trained for this specific event well
that's much sport yeah I can watch that
that's a sporting event so I can
like that type of fighting but I can't
watch anything else so you don't like if
you don't like pickup games at the park
yeah we're delete and then you got to do
it's like hey what's up you want to play
one-on-one I don't like it cuz he's
something it's just with their fists
yeah I don't like it good sad what a
[ __ ] bus dude what way does it make
you problems getting hurt that was
getting I don't what is that really even
if they deserve it if they didn't know
if they deserve it a lot of times you'd
catch it in the middle if they deserve
it then I'm like okay Karma but I just
don't want to see it like I don't I
don't get any sort of fulfillment like
oh I'm happy I saw this like I would I
would have had a better life for sure on
it on I don't get it so many people like
it's like they're actively look at the
pain part of it it's a guy thing just
leave it at that if you see like a guy
like let's say skateboard and fault like
those fail videos they don't like oh no
I can't do that you don't fail videos I
like that fail videos if I know they're
okay but like if like it's a failed
video right like he's like bombing a
[ __ ] hill and then he goes into the
street and a car hits him on are like oh
that's a death videos any what's up when
it's my wife girls are like Lake Havasu
vodka and then the [ __ ] a TV like
pitches for no I still feel really bad
God did I hate this girl more and more
every day dirtiest dog I'm right there
with you David I don't know man yeah I
thought you was tough yeah how do you
feel about so for me if a girl is
provoking the guy and the girl is
physically hitting the guy in my book
I'm like she has a right to defend save
save a lot of people don't feel that way
I mean that's damage but I worry what's
your definition but like she's like if
she's like yeah like what she was just
doing like actually like pushy so he's
like like closed fist
boom or is it like just hey get off that
should be the first step
it should be like get off and then if
she's like wailing on him then I'm like
I mean you kind of
I should defend himself like if my girls
like that on me the first thing I just
pull her tongue out and then I [ __ ]
Tommy to be a defense is lies right cuz
you can say like oh yeah oh she's a lady
but what if she's a 7-foot [ __ ] WWE
wrestler Jill but yeah baby punch me
fighting for my life I saw this in high
school there's this guy that got kicked
out of school Africa for war but he's
like one of those like ghetto ass like
those they just [ __ ] up but either way
he came on campus it's not funny but it
was kind of funny because the dude's
hell is short hey he just walked up I
literally saw this girl from the office
all the way to where her class was it
was like her home at class he walks up
to her he cuz she goes what are you
doing here he just go punches her in the
nose she just starts bleeding but I
started laughing because he was like
five foot two it was so funny but so bad
but he literally just came up and
punched her nose and just walked off
campus I don't know I don't know what it
was about he was in jail for some other
stuff later on but then that [ __ ] was
like one of the funniest things I ever
saw but very terrible cuz I think she
had a broken have you seen the video
where uh it's this little person I think
they're at a gas stop right so you can't
see the person recording I just
imagining it but then you just see the
car right so he's like in this SUV
that's lifted and then you see this
little person just jump out of it then
they put them with Super Mario
and that vial up in the camera I think
that's what I found bunnies the dude
just could not stop laughing and to get
a hot back in that wasn't the funny part
it was just the dude cracking the [ __ ]
up
see I mean you have to watch somewhat
like the street fight stuff where the
guy is such an obnoxious [ __ ] I've
seen so I've seen it you saw that one
Mexican do or he was like [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] the guy in the motor oh
yeah and he's like stay away stop yeah
no way yeah and he gets lit up and then
he comes back I've seen a lot of it here
but I've never liked a whole yeah like
I'm just like whoa that's a moment that
it had to get there ooh boom fights do
you ever watch them no I can't watch
that that's the first thing that made me
feel like a shitty person actively
searching bah bah bah bah fights is sad
when I see that because they're like
roll up and doesn't even make like the
homeless guy out of a sleeping bag and
use permanent marker and draw on their
face that's I never seen that you went
that far and there used to be a it was
like jackass but it was called bum
fights and they would make a fight for
sandwiches yeah they would pay them the
fight but they'll pay them to like put
tattoos on their forehead spray paint
their face it was a sad like that's just
sad I know it's so sad them in black I
kept watching oh yeah
you kept watching you [ __ ] I
kept watching my favorite part that I
hate myself about is when do you see the
Steve Irwin parody hunters he would
dress up like Steve Irwin and then wall
bums [ __ ] sleeping he would grab them
hog-tie them and I'm like this is
bizarre this is a - [ __ ] on earth it's
so [ __ ] up I just can't stop watching
and I couldn't stop watching
[Music]